[Música]
i
ah
[Música]
les quiero hacer una pregunta que los
mueve o los mantiene en movimiento yo lo
voy a contar desde mi caso desde mi
breve historia de vida como deportista
bueno yo soy misionera como cualquiera
de ustedes también una familia
convencional hija de familia muy
trabajadora éramos tres hermanos
ésta era yo una niñita sin corriente
pero tuve una particularidad cuando yo
nací era muy grande era una nena de 4
kilos 800 y en el parto al ser un parto
normal me lesionaron el brazo derecho y
se denomina trastorno de plexo braquial
para que por ahí así como ven a la nena
que está ahí oa mí no sé qué problema
tiene bueno yo tengo la limitación en el
brazo derecho esto así no lo puedo hacer
sin movimientos no tengo la misma fuerza
o aprensión y esa es la limitación que
tengo que lo tengo de nacimiento pero a
mí nunca me hicieron ver esa limitación
nunca me hicieron sentir limitada nada
ni para jugar ni para ser niña ni para
hacer mi travesura
siempre me sentí normal porque al ser de
nacimiento lo tenía sumamente
incorporado que tener qatar del pelo
tenía que sostener me a la pared al
tener que alcanzar algo me tenía que
ayudar con la otra mano pero en cambio a
mí me encantaba el deporte una de las
materias que más me gustaba era la
educación física
la clase favorita mía cuando jugaba al
voley se revolcaba en el piso observa la
pelota cuando hacía vertical lo hacía
con una manía portando un poco con la
otra media luna también hice varios
deportes como natación gimnasia
artística y voley todo
extra-curriculares de la escuela pero lo
podría hacer solamente para practicar no
para hacerlo de manera competitiva
porque justamente por la limitación del
brazo no podía competir por ejemplo en
voley mixto que es valjean dobles porque
no podía al mismo tiempo
después natación la braza no la podía
ser perfecta para tener la velocidad y
eliminarse artística por ejemplo es muy
importante la postura yo lo podía hacer
pero no lo podía no podía competir no
podía hacer las presentaciones y
en cambio yo iba a todos los
entrenamientos iba a todas las prácticas
iba todas las veces la semana que había
me iba lo hacía con todas las ganas pero
sabía que no lo podía practicar
hasta tenía la bici como cualquiera una
usted que puede tener una bici para
moverse para la casa de sus amigos lo
usa para ir a la escuela y a veces
pasear en la costanera pero no no
conocía el ciclismo a nivel competitivo
yo me acuerdo que iba a la costanera a
pasear y veía los dos ciclistas y decía
y esta gente disfrazada porque no sé si
alguna vez un ciclista que tiene toda la
ropa de colores con muchas publicidades
casco en las bicis re lindas y yo decía
y esta gente bueno hasta que una vez me
tocó tomar contacto con uno de ellos
cuando yo tenía que arreglar mi bici
para ir a arreglar mi bici que se había
descompuesto entonces de camino a la
facultad
paréntesis esto pues ya cuando tenía 21
años
voy a llevar a la está visible teoría
que me queda de paso la facultad y ahí
conozco a una persona esta persona que
es el dueño de la bicicletería que me
iba a arreglar la bici y me dice y ahí
veo trofeos veo fotos y ahí me invita a
entrenar al circuito del parque la
ciudad del que está acá al fondo
bueno entonces
en este momento lo pensé bueno dejé mi
bici para de arreglar y bueno os lo
pienso comentó a mi casa cuando voy a
buscarla digo si voy a ir
entonces me explica dónde queda porque
ni conocía el circuito como le decían o
sea ya existía el ciclismo
entonces digo voy y entonces me
encuentro acá y vengo a partir de ahí
empieza a venir seguido ven visual y
tres de la semana me prestan una bici
que había en el circuito muy similar
conozco a la persona que cuidaba lugar
que también al corredor miguel camargo
que ahora también se encuentra presente
me empieza a dar algunos ejercicios
después ya empieza a pedalear conmigo en
el circuito empezamos a salir a la ruta
y después empiezan a entusiasmar y me
dicen que ya hay carreras y a los meses
se venía en la primera fecha del
campeonato misionero entonces es ahí
donde bueno voy a competir voy a probar
y hay buena la riesgo en la categoría
que es de aficionado en los
principiantes es la única mujer y todo
varones van han sacado como tres vueltas
en saber mi carrera pero bueno es normal
era mi primer carrera recién comenzaba y
lo lejos de de sentirme mal quise seguir
entrenando
le muestro una foto
ahí es cuando voy a mi primer nacional y
este es mi guel camargo el que lo
comento que fue mi primer entrenador
acaba de posadas
entonces ahí es cuando me engancho con
la bici porque la bici me permitía
competir me permitía ser deportista algo
que siempre lo tenía acá como inquieto y
bueno siempre cuando venían los juegos
cada cuatro años yo me reenganchado
mirando y todos los deportes lo hacía
como le dijera para practicar y con el
ciclismo se me dio que el brazo no me
limitaba para hacerlo competitivo
entonces llega un momento en que yo me
preparo como objetivo cuando empieza a
conocer más del ciclismo que existe el
ciclismo de pista ya es como pongo
objetivo preparar un nacional de pista
el nacional de pista se corre en un
velódromo no sé si ustedes alguno conoce
que es el óvalo de 250 con la pared
pareciera levantada que es la bici sin
freno que pareciera que pedaleamos sobre
la pared bueno yo quería correr esa
competencia pero nunca había andado en
un velo derman entonces buscó la manera
y los medios para entrenar en un
velódromo y ahí donde me voy a rafaela
santa fe por una semana
el velódromo a probar a andar en un
velódromo antes de ir a competir
directamente con ellos cuando conozco a
cruz ciclista rafael a la familia
rafaela y él norbert capella compito ese
nacional y después de eso viene la
invitación de esta persona
el viejo capella decimos nosotros me
invita a irme a vivir a rafaela me dice
podrías andar muy bien en ese nacional
no había hecho me da yo no he hecho nada
pero él vio algo y me dijo podría cantar
muy bien
benítez a rafael a vivir yo estaba
haciendo mi tesis todavía no me había
recibido entonces lo pienso y luego lo
llamó por teléfono le digo que sí sí hoy
esa invitación para mí fue una gran
oportunidad y vila como la posibilidad
de poder crecer como deportista de poder
intentar ser mejor deportista y siempre
aquí tuve así tenía esas ganas de salir
y de probar cosas nuevas de conocer
gente nueva y con esta invitación lo vi
como una
acelere emite si todo lo que pude y en
marzo 2011 me fui a rafaela me dieron
mis padres mamá en papá en el auto
me acuerdo que llegando ellos me
preguntan está segura de lo que quería
hacer te aseguro que es venir y yo
estaba completamente seguro que si
quiero estaba con todas las ganas nos
veía miedos no veía limitación
yo quería probar era una oportunidad y
quería probarlo por supuesto ellos no
estaban tan contentos porque iban a
dejar una una hija entonces llegamos al
club y me muestran este es el lugar que
tenemos para vos era un salón gigante
casi vacío sucio entonces nos pusimos a
limpiar con mi mamá todo el salón a
ponerlo en condiciones colchón en el
piso sin muebles pero yo ese salón vacío
lo oí como salón vacío en el que yo iba
a llenar o yo a proyectar lo que yo
quería hacer en mi vida que no sabía
bien que quería pero algo quería hacer
entonces al otro día se van y yo me
quedo ahí quedó en rafaela y bueno acá
estoy me tengo que hacer cargo en lo que
quise y de la decisión que tome fui a
buscar trabajo
porque yo lo que no quería es que esta
decisión que yo tomé sea un peso
económico para mi familia yo como
orgullosa que soy decía yo me voy a
hacer cargo y como sea me las voy a
arreglar entonces a los 15 días
aproximadamente
luego de entregar entrevista de
entregarle de currículo consigo en una
agencia de turismo y ahí es cuando ya el
que me tomo sabía que yo estaba en
rafaela con el objetivo de entrenar bien
y prepararme
así estas son fotos mías de mis inicios
en rafaela esta bici es la primera vez y
la ruta que me compro
son fotos de corriendo ya y ahí es
cuando entrenando en rafaela empieza a
mejorar mejor empieza a andar bien a
nivel nacional y ahí es cuando en 2012
logró ser campeón argentina de velocidad
todo hablando el ciclismo convencional
yo no sabía que existía el ciclismo
adaptado en ese momento
entonces
después 2012
pine 2012 cuando yo vengo a posada
siempre por las fiestas me me toca
volver a rafaela porque yo trabajaba y
volviendo la ruta mi entrenador me dice
ni bien llegue él benítez que te tengo
que comentar algo llegó y lo primero que
me dice es hay una concentración con la
selección como usas campeón argentinas
te van a probar te van a dar la
posibilidad así que te vas a tener que
ir a mar de plata imagínate yo estaba
había venido posadas simplemente vine a
pasar las fiestas ya mantenerme no
estaba entrenando intenso como para ir a
concentrar con la selección
y
obviamente no iba a dejar pasar la
oportunidad
hasta que bueno tengo que comentar el
trabajo llegué de mis vacaciones pero me
tengo que ir porque tengo la posibilidad
de concentrar con la selección esa
concentración fue dura para mí bueno
como estar en la selección no va a ser
fácil pero tenía que demostrar una
manera que yo estaba en condiciones
aunque yo no había estado entrenando
como para estar en un panamericano pista
lo que se estaba preparando
era para una especialidad que no era mi
fuerte yo preparaba más velocidad y esta
prueba iba a ser una prueba de medio
fondo pero yo igualmente traté de
demostrar que podía estar
así es bueno termina la concentración
sin noticias
vuelvo a rafaela y no me llama el
técnico entonces yo no sabía si quede o
no quede y ahí es cuando los días
llamamos al técnico digo quiero saber si
viajo no porque me tendría que organizar
imc si todas las chicas que estaban en
la concentración viajan faltaba cinco
días para irme a méxico yo tenía que
avisar en mi trabajo pues tienen que
encontrar a alguien tenía que acomodar
mi material
el jefe le digo bueno renuncio usted
sabe que yo vine acá para para por la
bici por el ciclismo y me da la
oportunidad de viajar así que voy a
tener que irme y yo entiendo que tomen a
alguien porque usted necesitan estar en
enero plan de temporada nos vemos bueno
contame cómo te van más a la vuelta
entonces ahí es cuando yo invito por
primera vez la celeste y blanca
la ropa de la selección argentina y esta
es la prueba 2 y la del medio esta es la
prueba persecución por equipos que me
toca competir bueno pasa este
panamericano
vuelvo a rafaela obviamente contenta por
haber sido parte de la selección haber
tenido esta experiencia pero sin trabajo
pero super contenta
hace que ceda que una compañera mía del
entrenamiento de todas las tardes en el
velódromo una bioquímica su si
necesitaba una persona para para su casa
y es que yo me ofrezco a limpiar su casa
como como hacía con la agencia entrenada
por la mañana he trabajado por la mañana
y entrenado por la tarde con sus y lo
mismo
limpiaba por la mañana y entrenada por
la tarde
así es que después te panamericanos como
que uno empieza a ganar como más
confianza se empieza a animar un poco
más en las carreras por ahí uno ya
empieza a tener más confianza y a los
meses de este panamericano soy campeona
argentina de ruta que es otra prueba
completamente distinta que será de fondo
a lo que yo preparaba pero fui campeona
argentina de ruta después de eso
ahí es cuando los de la selección ya en
esa concentración en el viaje vieron que
yo tenía una limitación en el brazo y
como viendo que yo iba muy bien el
ciclismo convencional y ganaba dos
carreras empezaron a entusiasmarse
conmigo entonces después de este de esta
carrera en san luís se comunica martín
ferrari el técnico de la selección
argentina de ciclismo adaptado y me
comenta la posibilidad de ir con ellos a
que me evalúan los médicos
internacionales para ver si yo entraba a
la categoría c5 para los que no nos
ubican mucho ciclismo adaptadas es otra
rama del ciclismo que son aquellas que
compiten aquellas personas que tienen
alguna discapacidad van a ver gente sin
un brazo sin una pierna la bici doble es
donde pedalean los ciegos atrás son los
ciegos van con un guía después los que
andan en silla de ruedas son los que
andan en hand bike
los que pedalean con las manos el
ciclismo adaptado y yo estoy en
categoría hace 5 de mínima discapacidad
que son aquellos los cds somos los que
andamos la bici común de dos ruedas
puede ser una manera
bueno entonces viajo con ciclismo
adaptado y si entre la categoría 65 la
de mínima discapacidad ahí es cuando
cambia mi vida cambió mis objetivos
deportivos personales y empiezo a
trabajar por eventos internacionales de
ciclismo adaptado y en el 2014
medalla de plata en la prueba de scratch
en el mundial de pista de aguascalientes
méxico
ese es mi primer podio internacional
imagínense primero vestir la celeste y
blanca como fue en el panamericano y
luego ver la bandera de nuestro país en
un mástil un podio internacional
imagínense bueno ese es el primer podio
y ahora este es un podio actual de este
año 2018
han pasado cosas lindas y cosas no están
lindas desde que yo decidí tomar este
camino
he conocido gente extraordinaria que me
ha ayudado
a estos a estas decisiones que yo tomé
de encaminarme en el deporte y puedo
decir yo soy licenciada en turismo ya
pero igual sigo siendo deportista y sigo
eligiendo este camino como deportista
porque a pesar de estas dificultades o
estas alegrías
estas personas como el norbert capella
esto es una verdad son un nacional
cuando yo fui campeón argentina
o
esto qué es un abrazo en un mundial de
pista y este es martín ferrari
la otra persona extraordinaria que
conozco en mi camino
gracias a todas esas personas
que me han ayudado
y
canción sumamente importante para que yo
siga
y no me rinda
por qué
por ejemplo
así como la foto del podio entonces son
fotos de no podio
esta británica fue tercera o cuarta esto
fue en los juegos paralímpicos de río y
así otras carreras también que no se me
han dado
y estos malos y buenos altibajos
y cantidad de cosas que tenía que
superar puedo decir que gracias a dios
soy una de las afortunadas que puedo
vivir del deporte pude dedicarme al
deporte a pesar de que ya tengo una
profesión de ellis island turismo pero
yo elijo todavía el deporte hasta donde
me dé el el físico
y soy una afortunada porque estoy bueno
becada de la nación y gracias a esta a
esta beca puedo mantenerme y mantenerme
en el deporte y seguir apostando porque
con la beca yo también apuesto mi
rendimiento
tuve la suerte también de integrar un
equipo profesional femenino estoy en el
equipo femenino
tengo la posibilidad de viajar y de
entrenar me hace mi preparaciones en
europa por eso me considero sumamente
afortunada en eso de poder dedicarme y
hacer lo que me gusta hasta donde pueda
y lo aprovechó al máximo porque no sé
cuánto puede durar esto así que
yo le digo que hay algo que a mí me
sigue moviendo acá adentro que no sé qué
es porque obviamente me desanimé muchas
veces hay cosas que me salieron bien hay
cosas que no me salieron bien me
desanimé muchas veces he pasado momentos
duros como por ejemplo pasar cumpleaños
sola en el exterior porque está teniendo
haciendo una preparación lejos pero yo
estaba convencida de que lo ideal era
preparar allá afuera en este evento se
me hice cargo sufrí yo haré de todo pero
listo estamos acá hay que seguir
entrenando
estas estos que me desanimé me volvía a
poner fuerte
y esto es lo que también me han dicho
una vez todo tiene un costo tu poder
tener un costo haberme quedado y no
haber hecho nada y también tuvo su costo
haberme ido he vivido cosas
extraordinarias y nunca imaginé haber
vivido porque como ya saben no conocía
el ciclismo competitivo así que era
descubrir en cada momento en cada
carrera las condiciones de uno las
caídas las personas extraordinarias 12
este costo de haber elegido e irme para
que no me arrepiento para nada
y voy a seguir prefiriendo el costo de
haberme animado a intentarlo a probar y
a seguir eso que me mueve dentro por eso
el mensaje que yo quisiera dejarles a
ustedes que son jóvenes que están en la
posibilidad de tomar una decisión
dónde hacer algo todavía
es que se animen a intentar o que
busquen eso que lo puede mover bien
adentro que no saben que es yo no sabía
no está bien no sé bien que es porque
todavía sigo buscándolo por eso me sigo
moviendo por eso sigo manteniendo más
movimiento y literalmente mi bici es ese
medio que me sigue llevando a moverme a
seguir mejorando a seguir superándome
por eso busqué en eso que lo moda dentro
que puede ser el deporte que puede ser
el arte la música la tecnología lo que
sea pero busquen eso y no sé quién con
las ganas o con ese saborcito de que
esto que me entusiasma que esto que me
mueve así que lo mejor es quedarse con
el gusto decir bueno al menos lo intenté
y me saqué las ganas hice lo que es nada
más
[Aplausos]
[Música]